ça me dérange pas vraiment celle des
missions torse nu
c'est très gentil de votre part quel
oiseau peut-être fous masqués ou zizi
paul
burro masqué ou zizi le coucou c'est pas
le coupé pas les bloquer sandrine une
drian c'est le bruant masquer le bruant
zizi
et le bruant fou d'un petit passereau
d'europe et d'asie
voilà le gris du dit on va commencer par
une idée
que des mineurs
sabri admirer ce splendide 1
19 et 1 signé par le rappeur franco xian
les bijoux de famille n'ont jamais mieux
porté leur nom se sont pris trop de milo
une paille pour votre coup 30 bravo mais
je n'aurais pas dit mieux voilà pourquoi
je ne rajouterai rien est ce que vous
savez j'ai une question très importante
est ce que vous savez combien mesure le
zizi
eh bien il mesure 17 cm quand même ce
qui fait ce qui fait ça dépend qui en
fait voilà c'était une info importante
on se souvient des propos complotistes
de juillet molson haro sur le virus et
le vaccin et il n'a visiblement pas
apprécié d'être interrogé sur ce sujet
par une femme
je ne pouvais pas m'attendre à autre
chose de toi tu dors en pensant à moi tu
es amoureuse de moi c'est assez ridicule
ridicule parce qu'à partir du foot hub
avec bastos moi je comprends pas
pourquoi tu tapes des cris de sales usa
franchement belle et moi ça passe pas
c'est physique on n'arrive pas à se voir
moi c'est une fille à qui je n'oserais
même pas là à l'extérieur franchement un
moment donné va faire terrasse les
académiciens m tendre leurs oreilles
vers les quartiers populaires ce sont
les plus créatifs évidemment et les
immortels intègre chaque année dans le
dictionnaire de nouveaux termes
populaires et c'est d'ailleurs cyclique
l'adverbe trop c'est trop bien on
l'entend à longueur de journée voulait
déjà dire beaucoup à l'époque de clovis
les jeunes par donc ancien français sans
le savoir vous voulez vraiment humaine
même si déjà vous aurais voulu mettre un
truc moi j'aime bien la simplicité mais
voilà devant j'ai assuré vous pouvez
vraiment tout ce que vous voulez vous la
compacte et sur instagram et vous lui
demandez tout ce que vous voulez vous
savoir que c'est une maison de couture
libanaise voilà fait ça on libani
d'ailleurs natale et je vous déconseille
d'utiliser le mot ball aus parce que
vous risqueriez de paraître pour une
ringarde mais de ouf j'avoue je crois je
vais vous écoutez j'ai bien retenu la
leçon vous avez vu vous êtes parfait tu
commences à ce que tu sois tatoué alors
je suis tatouée parce que je suis bête
tu étais où pour te dire tu as toi ce
que j'ai fait un pari avec un copain
péter ou pour toujours ta tués c'était
en californie c'était à los angeles
jamais moi j'aimerais peut-être parce
qu'après ça ne sauve a pu mais moi non
plus j'aimerai pas être tatoués je me
suis fait tatouer pour des bêtises et
maintenant savent s'en va pas je suis
d'accord j'approchais tatouages or si on
peut éviter le tatouage vient le temps
des regrets
rajouter je veux noie dans un verre de
larmes bonsoir que recrue est là pardon
que recurt la guérir que récurer la wii
sucre etc eh oui c'est qu'elle écoute à
des comités molécule est un jeune dirais
qu'il est là dit il aime les belles
choses bastos et puis déjà
bastos et une guêpe ben ça c'est une
abeille d'assassinât put chine et
partout bastos et une test pcr battant
c'est un anti génie qui est là pour
tester tout le monde chaud ou alors
celui-là savage ils l'aiment bien plutôt
parce que je suis là c'est le prénom de
ma fille ava
par contre j'en ai fait un il est
vraiment moche est vraiment vraiment nul
et je les fais pas ce que j'ai fait un
pari j'ai des copains qui voulait se
faire tatouer moi je voulais faire comme
eux donc je les fais et lui voilà
celui-là c'est en plus nuls parce que
c'est le logo d'un film qui s'appelle le
parent
alors faire ça c'est encore déjà le
tatouage n'est pas génial mais en faire
ça c'est encore plus dur bonjour
monsieur c'est pour un sondage merci
bonjour c'est pour un sondage monsieur
bonjour c'est pour un sondage
bonjour c'est pour un sondage bonjour
c'est pour un sondage non c'est une
émission assez dingue quand même quoi
faire du dating avec des agriculteurs
mais quelle idée de génie quoi en vrai
la plupart des agriculteurs que tu
rencontres sont des gens vraiment sympas
charmant avec qui tu te marres et que
très souvent pour te remercier ils font
boire des petites bio et que moi j'étais
bourré vraiment l'après midi face à cet
échec je sors le décolleté et vous allez
voir ça change tout non seulement
j'attire le regard de ces messieurs mais
aussi leur attention et tout devient
plus facile
bonjour deux petites questions monsieur
pour un sondage
bonjour monsieur
c'est bourrin s'est vite faire
c'est pour un petit sondage je voulais
savoir est ce que vous faites attention
au regard des gens
un titre qui laisse trois places hélas à
l'imagination
il
[Musique]
et c'est l'occasion pour le réalisateur
de l'émission de nous en mettre plein la
vue avec des effets vidéo absolument
mirifique
oui
êtes vous gênés par des femmes en
topless à la plage ou à la piscine
est-ce que vous avez regardé au moins
une fois mon décolleté pendant ce
sondage sur wii
aurait été un blizzard différemment